je te remercie de nous accorder cette
entrevue en fin de campagne comme ça
fatiguée non écoute ça a été une longue
à l'écouté sa tête c'est une longue
campagne mais une bonne campagne
on est fiers de l'énergie positive qu'on
aimait quand on est positif ces mots et
un ans et moins fatiguée parce que vous
êtes sur une lancée le parti libéral on
voit ça il y avait une course à trois
mais là clairement vous avez pris la
tête
comment est ce que le parti libéral qui
est quand même un vieux parti qui a joué
le jeu de l'alternance réussi à incarner
le mieux le changement mieux que le npd
on on a reconnu que depuis plusieurs
élections le parti libéral avait un peu
trop pris les gens pour acquis elle
n'avait pas passé ce temps d'écouté et à
apprendre des priorités des gens alors
ça fait trois ans que je travaille à
travers le pays pour rencontrer les gens
les écouter et pour bâtir une vision une
plateforme qui répondent aux réels
besoins des canadiens et c'est ce dont
on parle depuis des semaines alors
qu'est-ce qui s'y différence vous
proposé par rapport justement aux
néo-démocrates qui disent incarnait
aussi les changements
monsieur mulcair a fait le mauvais choix
il ya un choisi d'équilibrer le budget
de monsieur un peu à tout prix ce qui
veut dire qu'il ne peut pas rêver ce tir
maintenant dans nos régions dans nos
municipalités dans nos infrastructures
de transport ou de routes ou même de
logements sociaux
il avale et l'infrastructure est ce que
ce n'est pas vieille politique ça tous
les tous les gouvernements va l'investir
dans les amines et deux de faire le pari
de la franchise de dire nous allons
faire trois ans de déficits modeste pour
pouvoir investir 60 milliards de dollars
c'est c'est plus que n'importe quel
autre gouvernement dans l'histoire du
canada l'autre chose que monsieur
mulcair a choisi de ne pas faire que
j'ai choisi de faire c'est de baisser
les impôts pour la classe moyenne en les
augmentant pour les portions des mieux
nantis et ses bases et non sur une
vision de gauche ou de droite c'est une
vision de ce dont on a besoin pour créer
des opportunités danse
donc ce changement c'est pas juste une
question d'image c'est pas juste une
question de génération o o plus que ça
on offre ce dont les gens ont réellement
besoin parce qu'on a écouté
monsieur mulcair est un peu de
difficulté maintenant parce que les prix
les québécois pour acquis et hiller à
faire des gardes eric sont moins bonnes
que ce qu'on a déjà et seulement 8 ans
il offre un salaire minimum national
auquel 99% des gens qui travaillent pour
un salaire minimum vaut pour recevoir
puis veut rouvrir la constitution avoir
une méga rondes de débats là dieu c'est
pour ça que les gens veulent mais en
termes de vision qu'est ce que vous
proposez parce que les gens se demandent
d'ailleurs est ce que c'est votre vision
est ce que c'est la vision des gens qui
vous entourent
est ce que ça vient bien de vous qu'est
ce que vous voulez comme j'ai grandi
dans un pays extraordinaire où un
gouvernement était là à pour créer des
opportunités pour les six points gagnés
à de gagner leur vie et de prospérer
j'ai grippe et j'ai grandi dans un pays
qui avaient une image à l'international
qui étaient présentes qui s'occupait de
l'environnement on a énormément de
choses qu'on a perdu depuis dix ans de
stephen harper dont vous voulez quoi
revenir en arrière à ce que canal est ce
que c'est possible dans ce n'est pas une
question de revenir en arrière c'est une
question de bâtir ensemble pays qui est
à notre image qui reflète nos valeurs et
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que je passe
tellement de temps au québec pour parler
aux québécois du fait que le canada a
besoin que les québécois se réengagent
au sein d'un gouvernement
ah ça fait longtemps que le québec vote
peu plus son opposition
il est temps d'avoir des voix québécoise
forte au sein d'un gouvernement canadien
pour que le gouvernement canadien
reflète mieux les valeurs pas juste des
québécois mais de tous les canadiens
mais à votre parti fait une remontée
mais surtout chez les anglophones et les
allophones commence à les convaincre les
québécois qui borde le parti libéral
depuis le rapatriement la constitution
par votre père en 1982 depuis l'échec de
l'accord du lac meech auquel votre père
contribuer encore une fois alors comment
vous allez les convaincre vous savez les
québécois
francophones comme anglophones comme l
iphone ne me parle pas beaucoup de
constitution il parle pas beaucoup de
négociations sur sur des désaccords
entre les provinces
une part de leur emploi il parle de la
croissance économique
il parle du rôle du canada dans le monde
et c'est à ce niveau là qu'on a bâti une
plateforme qui répondent aux priorités
des gens n'étant selon vous qu on
pardonne au parti libéral
j'ai pas une question pardonner c'est
une question de démontrer que le parti
libéral est en train de travailler
extrêmement fort pour démontrer un qu'on
a compris où on a perdu le chemin dans
les années passées et d'être encore une
fois à l écoute des gens nous présenter
une équipe jeune dynamique de candidats
travers le pays qui ont un mais ici au
québec aussi qui ont une expérience et
une vision apporté au sein d'un pays
fort mais monsieur mulcair dit j'ai
besoin de 35 sièges alors que le parti
libéral pour pour un changement de
gouvernement alors que pour un parti
d'une parti libéral ça on prend beaucoup
plus est ce qu a pas raison quand même
de dire ça mais sur vous le cheval comme
ça monsieur mulcair est en train de
prendre complètement les gens pour
acquis ils trichent suppose que tout le
monde qui auraient voté pour le npd pour
jack la dernière fois vont encore
automatiquement voter pour lui
je trouve que c'est un regard de faire
ça il faut respecter que les québécois
que les canadiens ont énormément de
choix et c'est ce que je dis tout le
temps je sais je sais très bien que vous
avez des choix alors regardez pas les
sondages
regardez nos plateformes regarder ce
qu'on est en train d'offrir et on sait
dans une élection tout le monde à zéro
siège
on se doit de gagner la confiance des
canadiens à travers le pays
et c'est pour ça que nous prenons
personnes pour acquis nous travaillons
très fort comme vous dites il faut
regarder notre plate forme parce que
quand même dans une élection les gens
votent par conviction mais par part
instinct aussi par émotion non les seuls
à la raison des gens y compris y compris
à la passion je sais que les gens
veulent un gouvernement qui est positif
quelqu'un qui ne fonctionne pas à part
miskine ripart attaque par division on a
eu dix ans mesure 1 but qui faisait ça
on a besoin de quelqu'un qui rassure et
qui rassemble au lieu de jouer sur la
peur la division mais en même temps les
gens veulent savoir que le gouvernement
peut jouer un rôle positif dans leur vie
et le fait qu'on donne une allocation
canadienne aux familles beaucoup plus
généreuse pour ceux qui en ont besoin
et qu'on arrête de l'envoyer envoyer des
chèques à des familles millionnaire même
si monsieur harper et monsieur mulcair
veulent continuer de la renvoyer d'échec
nous on a dit non on va couper ces
chèques pour les millionnaires
on veut leur donner plus aux familles
qui en ont besoin
ça c'est la raison mais c'est aussi
qu'on craint pour les gens et je suis
très très fier de la plate forme nous
avons bâti parce que nous n'avions bâti
en fonction de ce que les gens me disent
directement depuis trois ans est ce que
vous pensez qu après cette longue
campagne après ski ces années du
gréement à peu ça prend une majorité
coach comme tous les chefs de partis on
veut gagner ces élections on mesure un
peu l'a dit monsieur mulcair l'a dit moi
je sais que les gens ont besoin de mer
gouvernement et ce qui est beau dans les
élections c'est que c'est laisser les
électeurs qui vont choisir de quoi voir
la vie ou la santé un peu
mais on sent qu'il ya des gens qui
valaient vraiment du changement qui
après dix ans de monsieur harper sont
année ils veulent choisir a quelque
chose de positif les gens sont tannés de
voir être cynique et de voter contre ce
qu'ils veulent pas il est temps qu'on
vote pour une vision forte de ce que ce
pays peut être de ce que le gouvernement
peut faire pour les gens dans la vie de
tous les jours
c'est ce qu'on offre dont vous parlez de
changements je posais deux trois
questions un peu en rafale par exemple
sur les scientifiques
on sait qu'il ya beaucoup de
scientifiques qui ont perdu leur emploi
on sait qu'il ya eu 10 fermeture de
laboratoires de centres de recherche
parce que est ce que là on peut revenir
en arrière dit tout à l'heure on revient
pas en arrière mais là est ce qu'on peut
changer votre séjour
il faut ramener le recensement l'eau il
faut continuer de permettre aux
scientifiques de faire leur travail ne
pas les museler les permettent de parler
ouvertement de ce qu'ils trouvent
il faut avoir un gouvernement qui se
base sur les faits il est donné pour
juste parce que ça a été fait dans le
passé mais parce que pour être
compétitif pour faire les bonnes choses
dans les années à venir
on a besoin de nos chercheurs nos
besoins nos scientifiques et c'est pour
ça que le parti libéral investir
massivement à nos scientifiques aussi
sur les pouvoirs au bureau du premier
ministre on a vu ce que ça pouvait
donner ça a commencé sur votre page bien
entendu le dire déjà les ça et ça s'est
accentué beaucoup sous jean chrétien sur
stephen rapp
alors là dessus qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire comment est-ce qu'on change les
choses d'abord on attire des gens
extraordinaires en politique gdg des
candidats comme jean yves duclos comme
michèle audette comme mélanie joly des
jeux extraordinaires à travers le québec
et qui sont les gens de personnes qui
vont ainsi il se retrouve au conseil des
ministres vont avoir un impact fort et
une responsabilité
maintenant les ministres du gouvernement
un peu sont beaucoup plus porte parole
pour leurs ministères que décideurs et
responsables
moi je crois que ça prend un conseil de
ministres forts pour pouvoir gérer
gouverner un pays extraordinaire pour le
québec comme le canada mais aussi de
faire plus preuve de transparence
d'ouverture de réformes et l'accès à
l'information pour que ça s'applique au
bureau du premier ministre
être ouvert et transparent ces deux
choses c'est d'abord démontré que les
canadiens peuvent avoir confiance dans
leur gouvernement
parce qu'on a un gouvernement qui a
confiance dans les canadiens mais
deuxièmement ça permet de prendre de
meilleures décisions de meilleures
politiques quand on sait que ça va être
scrutée à la loupe de façon transparente
et ouverte qui va falloir justifier
qu'on a pris cette décision là parce que
c'était vraiment dans l'intérêt du pays
et non du parti au pouvoir et de dix ans
de monsieur un peu ça commence à
fatiguer les gens sur le sénat il ya une
vingtaine de nominations à qui doivent
être faites
est ce que vous allez faire est ce que
vous allez nommé des nouveaux sénateurs
oui je nommais des nouveaux sénateurs
mais dans un processus transparent
ouvert et sur des recommandations non
partisane on sait que les provinces vont
pouvoir de promouvoir et à faire mais
c'est finalement c'est le premier
ministre qui se doit de décider parce
qu'il a la responsabilité sur 1er mai
choisi des gens comme un patrick brazeau
pas manawan magda fille on doit tenir le
premier ministre responsable de ses
choix lors commerçants le verrons tout à
fait ici et c'est pour ça que nous avons
proposé une réforme du sien qui va être
beaucoup plus ouverte transparente mais
qui va enlever le favoritisme politique
et la partisanerie du sénat parce qu'on
a besoin d'une chambre ou à les intérêts
régionaux sont bien représentés au
canada c'était comment le canada était
fondée
et il ne faut pas ouvrir la constitution
les gens veulent pas dix ans de chicanes
constitutionnelles alors on est pris
avec le sénat donc comment est-ce qu'on
peut l'améliorer pour que ça représente
bien les valeurs les intérêts de nos
régions et des canadiens si jamais
on a un gouvernement minoritaire donc
clairement ça sera difficile pour un
gouvernement minoritaire conservateur
puisque tous d'accord et si c'est un
gouvernement minoritaire libéral vous
allez avoir besoin du npd après cette
campagne si difficile comment vous allez
faire
on est toujours espéré ce temps on a
toujours rester positif et moi comme
j'ai des critiques à l'égard du npd cpo
personnel c'est une question de dire
vous avez fait les mauvais choix
nous on a fait d'autres choix alors le
parti libéral a toujours su collaborer
avec d'autres partis ça sert pas la
première fois ci ça arrive que c'est un
gouvernement minoritaire au canada et de
mission formée non je trouve que ces
porcs c'est pas la chose à faire d'avoir
des chèvres qui est sont en train de
faire des manigances dans les coulisses
pour décider qui va contrôler quoi si
les canadiens qui vont décider qui
forment le gouvernement qui a sièges au
parlement et c'est tout parti de travail
en forme de le meilleur intérêt du pays
et façon ponctuelle dans les ententes
coups de feu toute la flore il reste
quelques jours à cette campagne est ce
que vous auriez imaginé ça en partant
vous étiez vraiment disons le
sous-estimé par vos adversaires
mes adversaires ont toujours eu leur
opinion sur moi moi j'ai toujours gardé
mon point de mire sur ce qu'il faut
faire pour offrir un meilleur
gouvernement canadien et nous on n'a pas
changé d'approché depuis trois ans quand
j'ai lancé ma campagne dans papineau
jeunes pour le leadership
j'ai parlé d'eux
de la classe moyenne et depuis ce temps
là avec notre notre plateforme notre
plan on parle de croissance pour la
classe moyenne
on continue de dire la même chose qu'un
gouvernement fédéral se peut d'aider
directement les citoyens et c'est ce
qu'on va faire vous allez à au québec ce
soir vous serez l'abonnement est ce que
vous pouvez gagner sans québec
je ne voudrais pas gagner sans le québec
il est temps que le québec se réengagent
au sein d'un gouvernement canadien pas
juste parce que c'est bon pour le québec
mais parce que c'est bon pour le canada
on a besoin d'une vision qui rassemble
tous les coins de ce pays c'est pour ça
que je travaille si fort à travers le
pays que ce soit à au saguenay que ce
soit à calgary
chantraine présenter une vision qui
rassemble positive y est un connaisseur
d'un gouvernement fédéral
alors vous souhaite une bonne fin de
campagne merci m donc merci beaucoup